a district court judge has found Clark
County ordinances on short-term rentals
unconstitutional now the court will go
back to review it putting several
ordinances on hold in the meantime
Madison Kimbrough joins us live outside
of District Court with what home share
hosts and renters are saying Madison
yes many breathing a sigh of relief
tonight as preliminary injunction give
short-term rental host hope that they
will be able to stay in business take a
listen
we don't have to worry about the kids
running down the hall of a hotel or save
money on food just sharing the costs and
it's completely more reasonable Abby
Payne is a cheer mom visiting Las Vegas
for a cheer competition and for several
years she and her family have been
staying at this short-term rental she
says not only is it convenient to have
all the kids in one place but it feels
safer too you may recall back in June a
County ordinance was passed with certain
regulations in place preventing several
hosts from operating successfully while
Thursday Clark County Judge Jessica
Peterson stating that the current
ordinance was quote unconstitutionally
vague and overbroad so now certain
Provisions in the ordinance will be put
on hold until the court can further
review them Jackie Flores and Lewis
korndike founders of the greater Las
Vegas short-term rental Association
pleased with this ruling the association
suing the entire State stating that
these regulations are violating people's
rights our hope is that Clark County
will actually pause things you know fix
the ordinance the city of Las Vegas has
their own ordinance the city of
Henderson also has their own ordinance
the city of North Las Vegas has their
own ordinance and of course
unincorporated Clark County has their
own but we are challenging not just the
Clark County ordinance but also the
state law which covers all of them and
as for those who are just trying to get
by business has been good but there's
still that concern that any day now they
could get shut down I'm still hanging in
there so and you know with everything
going up you know I I look forward to
every chance I get to run out my room
honestly I just wish that you know we
had a little bit more security you know
because I still don't know what's going
to happen and I still have to watch you
know how I rent out my place and all
that
as for some of those regulations being
challenged in the ordinance it states
that no more than 10 people are allowed
rentals must be at least a thousand feet
away from each other reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now